du sport à présent avec une discipline
qui ne sonne pas très locale et oui
saviez-vous que tour avait son club de
pelotte basque on vous emmène à présent
à la découverte de ce sport qui compte
quelques adeptes ici et si le tour
pelote basque compte sur la transmission
de la passion de parents à enfants il
espère également pourquoi pas séduire
des
néophites deux contre deux et un
objectif faire rebondir la pelote entre
les lignes vertes sans qu'elle ne sorte
du terrain Philippe vient de
briveelagill et la pelotte basque ça
fait 40 ans qu'il y joue il faut avoir
de l'adresse parce qu'on joue souvent
avec un instrument alors la pelotte
basque c'est riche de spécialité là
aujourd'hui c'est un tournoi à pala avec
une raquette en bois c'est un jeu un peu
particulier où on joue quand même assez
fort il faut il faut frapper se déplacer
c'est un sport qui demande quand même
pas mal des déplens énergétiques un
sport fatiguant mais toujours
fairep l'important c'est avant tout de
passer un bon moment et pour certains
c'est en famille papa m'a transmis ça
moi je l'ai retransmis à mon fils
Raphaël je l'ai retransmis à ma fille 10
et à mon épouse aussi donc j'ai converti
un peu tout le monde à la pootte vasque
j'ai commencé à l'âge de 4 ans et demi
et je suis jamais arrêté c'est pas que
la la puissance qui fait qui fait tout
c'est vraiment la précision la stratégie
et cetera donc c'est vraiment bien
plusieurs équipes ont fait des centaines
de kilomètres pour jouer l'Open national
de Touren organisé par le club touranjau
une manière de faire vivre la pelote
basque en dehors de ses frontières
d'origine moi à la base je suis
originaire du du Pays-Basque quand je
suis arrivé en Touren ou c'est le fait
déjà de dépasser Bordeaux de voir qu'il
y avait plus d'installations euh
notamment à l'extérieur qui permettaiit
cette pratique là alors que c'est
peut-être la pelote basque il y a pas
que les Basques qui jouent pour l' nel
là quoi il y a 300000 habitants sur la
métropole on va bien arriver à trouver
quelques imbéciles qui veulent bien nous
suivre quoi voilà un club indépendant
depuis maintenant 2 ans avec une
trentaine de licenciés pour rejoindre
les pilotesaries rendez-vous trois fois
par semaine au gymnase des Tourettes à
tour
Nord